obrigado tão pouco tempo é tanta coisa
pra dizer e é engraçado as perspectivas
diferentes eu sinto muito feliz porque
não sou santo e além disso sou ateu é o
que não é uma opção é obrigado a todos
aqueles que estão no twitter não
acreditar não é uma opção ser ateu é uma
falta de opções é é completamente
diferente
aliás também não é bem verdade eu
acredito é muitas coisas acredita em
muitas coisas de uma das coisas em que
acredita no pingo não sei se alguém
daqui sabe que o pingo propósito alguém
sabe que pingo
ae pra quem não sabe explicar facilmente
do que o pingo muitos de vocês já
conhecem dos lados que anda aí nos
restaurantes
basicamente é o cadáver de um pingüim
com um chapéu de cowboy do qual nós
comemos um cérebro que normalmente a
baunilha
mas para quem não sabe o pingo é isso
que eu pedi para me preparar e
apresentar isso é o pingo e esses que a
gente como restaurantes e adaptado isto
é um desenho animado que foi um grande
sucesso nos anos 80 eo pingo tem uma
particularidade domingo pode subir já
podemos tirar a imagem pessoas a ver
pessoas têm medo pingüins e coisa e o
que é importante é que o eu acredito eu
sou do tipo de pingo pingo é um desenho
animado que teve meus seguidores no
planetário tem uma particularidade é que
crianças até aos cinco anos
o pingo não fala nenhuma língua o pingo
fala pingo só servimos animado o els
falam entre 11 e falou com o irmão olha
uma foto em que um ok então foi tentar
um fofo eo fantástico é que em todo o
mundo de todas as nacionalidades todas
as crianças até aos cinco anos são
fluentes em pingo
e como faxina é que a partir dos 5 anos
dependendo dessas crianças começam ir
para níveis mais avançados no jardim
escola e vão para primarem começam a
aprender e começa o alvará com o sistema
da nossa sociedade em cima essas
crianças perdem essa capacidade inata de
falar em pingo sequer e ainda falo
moderadamente pingo ficar em algumas
coisas que falam pingo por isso eu vou
fazer toda a minha apresentação em pingo
para baixo vai ter show foi ao canteiro
central foi garantir que ela não se
calhar já levantamos ou eu ou meu nome é
é carlos moura eu faço tudo com calma e
facilitando a câmera e profissionalmente
desde 2003 anos quando ganhava a vida de
forma honesta falar pressa porque tem
pouco tempo para fazer essas coisas eu
quero minha vida de uma forma honesta
fez mais dez anos da rádio trabalhando
design comunicação tamanha publicidade
depois comecei a fazer stand up como vôo
deste palco os mais pequenos se em
palcos maiores como este ano já fui
muito feliz mas vamos também o título
vamos por exemplo ato visando agora
trabalha na televisão e onde faz coisas
completamente o parente mente diz parece
que não tem nada a ver com humor por
exemplo neste momento estou a coordenar
e articular programas como sempre à meia
noite quando tava no canal 2
já estive em kunar uma série de coisas e
fazer bonita e bibi e até a música fez é
que é uma coisa que se consome demasiado
em provisão é e teve que fazer uma série
de coisas neste momento estou a
coordenar conteúdos num programa também
tem muito a ver com humor porque o
programa a tarde é sua na tv
o fábio lopes
e sou eu acordar os conteúdos para
fátima lopes
eu sou estou vestido de azul e tem muita
porque tem muito mais a ver com o humor
tem a ver com emissões e então pediram
para vir cá hoje e para falar sobre o
rio e isso é uma coisa complicada eu
podia assumir isto uma forma simples rir
é uma reação física é uma resposta
física fisiológica ou humor
tal como espirros uma resposta
fisiológica algo está a incomodar por
exemplo os nossos canais ao fugitivo mas
a mais que isso pediram para falar sobre
o que é rir
arf aí a coisa complica não querem
primeiro pacto para aplicarmos o qr
temos que falar através de outras
perguntas adquirir através de outras
perguntas temos que saber afinal nós
rimos de que qualquer centelha qual é
feito o original como é que o riso
começa o que dá origem aos risos
temos que saber porquê ok já percebemos
carlos dá origem à crise mas porque
porque essa feliz que funciona e por que
é que o riso se torna nesta combustão e
finalmente para que para que serve rimos
fazer um espião toda a gente perceba que
serve única para os poros risco coisas
bica para fora
mas o riso serve porque é bom então
vamos ponto vamos primeiro a rir de que
o que provoca am em essa foi a isca
original que nos faz rir é fácil
o riso por suécia surge da tensão do
irão é que normalmente a toda a base do
riso econômico detetamos um erro quando
detetamos que algo não está bem ea
partida que então podemos rir várias
coisas aparentemente detetamos uma
anomalia se tu tava ninguém sair né
basicamente o flu vai andar na rua com
uma casca de banana e ao passar ao lado
não tem graça absolutamente nenhuma só
tem graça coisa correr mal saber um erro
e nós temos tendência é irmos seja do
absurdo das coisas mais disparos podem
disparos pode ser também do rio veículo
da figura triste do do boneco com pode
ser também do completamente impossível
ou pura e simples
rimos da constatação do real que é o
tipo de humor que a mim também me faxina
mais
mesmo assim nada com vai tentar perceber
porquê porque nós nos rimos baiano para
estudiosos e cientistas e psicólogos e e
e gente que brilha muito ativa em
escrever coisas e de desenvolver teorias
é que andam a cada vez mais com a teoria
tudo isto é explicado pela teoria da
evolução
e tudo isso realmente pode ser explicado
que vai poder usar farda não pode ser
mantida por cascais basicamente a mesma
mas o que acontece é que a teoria da
evolução na copa e temos pouco tempo mas
o que acontece é que a teoria da
evolução pode ir desde o darth vader até
a minha professora primária o que pode
acontecer o que acontece o que as
teorias atuais se defendem é que o riso
é o mecanismo que nosso cérebro
encontrou para nos premiar pela proteção
do euro e se isso hoje pode não parecer
importante
há milhares de anos quando estávamos no
meio da savana de caçadores o corretor
ou andávamos à procura de vagas há
qualquer coisa de repente percebemos a
diferença entre a união poderia ser a
diferença entre estar vivo ou será uma
opinião como é óbvio não é e essa
capacidade de natal e um leão o cérebro
primeiros e premiava nos libertando
dopamina serotonina cve todas as usinas
e vitaminas e companhia e casa das
chances criadas dentro do cérebro nas
soltando todos os químicos premiamos com
essa sensação de prazer para mim é
descobrir o erro a força gás fosse
espero conseguir estar vivo agora com
essa cana mas basicamente a teoria da
evolução pode explicar isto pode
explicar daí é que vem o riso de
tentarmos o erro de percebermos do nec
únicas coisas estão erradas portanto por
outras palavras rir é nada mais nada
menos do que saber
ver saber observar e saber do tentar pôr
só percebendo só sabendo ver é que a
gente consegue ver onde é que está o
erro
ela estava piava ea partir daí rios e
temos o nosso sentido de humor portanto
basicamente o humor é uma ferramenta que
o nosso cérebro desenvolveu uma
ferramenta mental de análises em que
analisamos o mundo connosco zaia onde
construímos a realidade há muitas vezes
através da desconstrução e há também o
riso é também não se enganem o riso é
uma prova de inteligência
alguns tinga do resto das escrituras na
função é uma característica tão nossa
tão humana universal que ultrapassa
cultura ultrapassa barreiras
linguísticas
eu não estou acreditando ser que quem ri
ou quem faz rir é mais inteligente que
os outros
eu estou apenas a dizer que o riso
realmente é uma prova desta inteligência
desta capacidade de análise do mundo que
nos rodeia detectar o erro
a capacidade de nos rirmos do dia havia
outra passa todas essas barreiras e nem
sequer é preciso legendas para
percebermos a graça estão dizendo que no
maravilhoso criador de uma falta não é
preciso de nós nos identificamos
mas além da cultura humor não um mouro
sentido de humor é uma coisa regional do
cálculo geral individual mas o riso em
qualquer país do mundo há pouco tivemos
aqui relatos de pessoas que atravessaram
o mundo de bicicleta e comunicaram
através de um sorriso e depois através
de linguagem gestual provavelmente
também tráfego muito boa sempre estou eu
a tentar fazer comida do messi
não sei porque é que me traiu quem
comemora méxico lembra uma razão
mas o riso ultrapassa isto é uma
ferramenta importante tão importante
para o nosso dia a dia tão importante
para a nossa vida esta capacidade de
distinguir duas coisas estamos atentos
de chile - as coisas
essa capacidade de observação é
importantíssimo e é muito muito mais do
que explicar a que horas a falar como
riso é fundamental como risa
libertadores como riso é terapêutico e
pode ser tranqüilo e que é utilizado o
yoga do riso por exemplo é autorizado
com crianças em hospitais através desse
maravilhoso trabalho que se espalhasse
os médicos lá espalhassem formais fazem
a exceção são os outros palhaços fazem
trabalho tão genial tomou é é uma forma
de enfrentar os medos os dramas do olhar
e descobrimos um mundo todos os dias e e
acima de tudo encarar as amarguras da
vida suspensão que o riso é só coisas
boas e é exatamente o contrário
irei capacidade de ver novos caminhos e
de estarmos focados na realidade de ser
capazes somos capazes de conhecer e
entender os erros
ninguém sair coisas boas o riso não
existem coisas boas todas as piadas só
existem sobre coisas mas ninguém
constrói uma piada sobre o indivíduo
chega à casa de cobra mulher nua na cama
sozinha
todo o riso é sempre em coisas margem e
isso tem esta capacidade
o riso tem capacidade de fazer com que o
ser humano e para as coisas mais para as
coisas mais negras mais triste mais
distantes da vida e ergot caixa e ronise
passa acima dessas amargura e ainda por
cima com sorriso nos lábios é é uma
ferramenta tão genuína do nosso cérebro
que nos permita olhar para as coisas
verdadeiramente mas e sorrirmos não sei
se você o fundo consegue ver a lei em
cima disso errar é humano
o teste porque há piadas mas é que pode
haver camaradas mil pçs como eu vou
atrás nas últimas filas e ao design
maravilhoso do time pra mim e estou
melhor relato do humor é o melhor relato
do que o riso
esta capacidade de olharmos para as
coisas más e mesmo assim rirmos
enfrentarmos esse dia a dia com riso
agora o que é extraordinário é que toda
a sociedade está construída de forma é
cortar esta ferramenta natural
eu estou convencido toda a nossa
sociedade foi construída de forma a
tentar colocar pro lado o riso eo humor
quase como coisas secundárias às vezes
em determinadas alturas com coisas
obscenas
lembro-vos que na época medieval opções
foram parar a fuga era porque tinham o
porquê saíam bastante eo riso é
considerado coisa do demo coisa do
demônio tanto sua carreira na fuga por
uma boa piada mas ainda hoje nós vivemos
isso porque estamos tão tão marcados por
uma sociedade industrial na sociedade
que vai de uma formação há pouco
falávamos antes de irmos para o almoço
falavam aqui sobre a escola informa como
escola coloca de parte a carreira
artística é em vez de fazer o que o
professor agostinho da silva tantas
vezes diz que desde as ferramentas mas
depois atira em dois globos e deixem
luzia prender não nós tentamos dar o
conhecimento já compactado já preparado
já pronto a comer que é pra vocês não
terem pensarem muito mais coisas e eu
sei que há muitos jovens aqui que na
casa de 20 anos e ao longo desses 20
anos e tenho a certeza absoluta de uma
coisa onde este 20 anos
vocês foram tratados muitas vezes como
atrasados mentais ao longo destes 20
anos
eu tenho más notícias é que nos próximos
20 30 40 50 anos você você continuar a
ser tratados como atrasados mentais que
a sociedade faz isso a ansiedade fases
desde que vocês são pequenos até que
vocês são grandes até no emprego o chefe
o gás mais sério talvez de uma forma
série escola pra vocês vocês torre no
trabalho alguém olha como forma de
confiança do outro lado é sacanagem
ocorrido não é bem visto nós somos
pessoas sérias só dá pra se molhar as
nuvens olha pro chão olha para baixo
limita tatua o pato a pequenez encara o
medo porque o medo dá muito jeito a
sociedade hoje que falamos sobre isso
medo da crise o medo é boa o medo
ministro da economia no parlamento o
medo disto e daquilo que nós assinamos
disseminamos um medo consumido fosse uma
coisa boa para manter esta gente toda
sua control e não queremos pessoas
pensem mais não queremos pessoas riam
mais queremos que as pessoas limitem a
fazer aquelas tarefas e não questionem
mais e quem fir é sinal que está a
questionar porque está a querer ver está
a querer ver mais um tempinho todos
vocês queiram ouvir frases como a mesa
nós brinca
importa também tem bons modos dos enta
direito é uma coisa que eu adoro essa
com certeza isso não tem graça nenhuma
frase frasco ganhe juizo e pior frase
que alguma vez me disseram que é escovar
está sério
não não não temos que provar esta série
não temos que provar isto a sério
nós temos que ir todos os dias com maior
seriedade possível
e aí uma grande diferença nós andamos ao
varejista sério demais
nós podemos levar isso com toda a
seriedade e continuarmos a rir com
consciência de fundos mais do que isto
nós somos mais ser humano é ser mais
é ser mais do que isso
o ser humano é ser um caminho mais do
que os conflitos as brasileiras porque
mesas dificuldades que nos tentam
impingir todos os dias os obstáculos e
por isso é que eu não vou falar do prec
o riso é uma ferramenta todos nós temos
disponível está dentro do nosso cérebro
está ali está à nossa disposição é uma
espécie de universo está ali pra que nós
quisermos usar cada um usa qualquer eu
uso no meu dia a dia uso no programa de
fátima lopes na tvi como usar nos
programas comuns em cima do palco comuns
quando voc foi quando vou tratar com
alguém em uma partição fã
pública uso em todo lado é uma
ferramenta que eu tento usar todos os
dias e tento manter desperto eu não vou
dizer para que eu vou dizer o porquê não
e vou explicar que ir
há muitas razões para crer nos rir
porque não deixamos a se sentarem se é
fundamental
temos que continuar a rir porque não
temos que nos recusar a semus mil cruz e
tudo à nossa volta parece que nos trata
como atrasados mentais a provisão de
trabalho nos trata como atrasados
mentais jogos superior e será que muitas
vezes tratam contra como atrasados
mentais e nós não somos atrasados
mentais
nós não somos amigos e acima tudo ir
porque não temos medo a turistas a
bandidos ao ego lacres nós sabemos que
há estudos mas não temos medo não temos
que ter medo das nossas fraquezas não
temos que ter medo das nossas
inseguranças e não temos que ter medo do
desconhecido
nós temos que nos deixar rir e não
devemos deixar contagiar o desespero
essa é a grande diferença e os é que a
pessoa que hoje que devem estar a dizer
tá bem exceto um cara bonito mas esse
que aliás todos pensarmos todos sabemos
bem que o riso é fundamental se todos
nós já pensamos isso nós estamos aqui
hoje dentro de uma sala a tentar
explicar um uns aos outros a importância
do riso
estamos provavelmente apenas lá fora a
vir obrigado mesmo até a praça
bom